[Music]
like how am i sounding did you put them
on you just throw one ear on holy [ __ ]
do this let's do it we have here today
Mays and gentlemen we got a good one
today hey I think he's biting me oh come
on Mike let me have going today we got
the real Tarzan in the house car then
and now cause in in the house king of
the jungle
Mike Holston I'm here with Mike Tyson
bro Amen man Oh any men hot boxing bro
you are a legend thank you no you
already know that but my life being a
Michael I'm the third Michael oh my
family you know
so Michael Jordan Michael Jackson like
Tyson might hosting oh yeah operated my
life to be what are you like y'all what
is it that you have in your head right
now
what's a tarantula have some type of
venom yeah yeah poison you know but
ain't gonna hurt you don't worry about
certain spiders different species have
what do they eat insects small bugs you
know sometimes small rodents the peds
ears good Mike how did you get into this
man you're an exotic animal specialist I
would say animal educator
conservationist animal ambassador I'm
just a voice for the voiceless you know
I love I love animals all my heart like
you know like you guys love boxing you
know and that's just that's what that
was my getaway oh it's my happy space I
started when I'm like four years old and
then a call you know that crazy guy
Steve Irwin of course that was my idol
well you know people look up to like
LeBron James and you know the Beatles
yeah y'all want to be like that crazy
guy Steve Irwin yeah bro so he rest in
peace some peace how nice is that right
is amazingly macro 19-footer Clarkie my
NGO Billy I love them
dude he was a best bro so four years old
man what was the first animal you had
contact with well I grew up with a pit
bull and a pick ax nice okay day one
okay
big huge stocky blue pit bull would you
know big huge chain on and yeah ears cut
you know but he's like my best friend
amazing and then I got my first real
animal at for trying to fly if I got a
boa constrictor for my birthday
wow I begged for it for about a year
until I got it that's amazing yeah and
your parents were just so yeah we'll get
you a pie oh no I freaking begged them
yeah you know I used to every time we
will pass a pet store or anything I'm
like I want a snake coming go in there
could we get this can we get this can we
get this what are your parents things
now my mom still thinks I'm a [ __ ]
lunatic
what she loves being supports it you
know yeah because she knows it makes me
happy because she knows the real me you
know yeah she's seen it from day one
till 25 in a couple days so you know 20
years worth believing in myself and now
I'm sitting here getting interviewed by
Mike Tyson no doubt don't get you it's
my first podcast ever really yeah first
time ever being on like that won't be a
mass we're honoured row to have a
monitor be here brother it's also not
and you're doing it with a tarantula on
your head when put on your head
I do not know you thank you thank you
got this broke this is gonna go viral
the podcast is gonna be hitting 20
million views let me see Mike Tyson what
a fat ass tarantula on his forehead
trust me bro trust me we're gonna find
him first I feel them I mean I want to
get this on that I can't do this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that man I gotta hold this I hold
him no way bro sorry
oh thanks he's chillin he's a cool
arachnid that's pretty dumb we're scared
of spiders I have a right to [ __ ] I'm
one of those guys you know [ __ ] I shut
my phone off - I'm scared the definite
thing he's cool amazing where does this
guy come from
oh I think these guys come from South
America so cars taken they have Chilean
Rose hair tarantula oh sure a smoother
species of spider is kind of calm okay I
have some tarantulas that's like reals
you know sporadic that move a lot will
address it with a real chill interesting
about them uses a skeleton like
tarantula dinah Chilean Rose here he's
cool bro you should do it I mean it's an
amazing animal it food has a podcast
what a tarantula knife for head and when
I say yeah you should have Tigers back
in the day bro you had Peck night yeah
well you was a bad man you are still the
baddest man on the planet you can let
this little punk-ass eight-legged spider
that weighs a quarter of a pound quarter
pound spider ten seconds good amazing
bro this is gonna go sick a tarantula my
Sorento sitting on the podcasts over
here hanging out on my boy Peter Parker
and Mike - oh [ __ ] hold on wasn't
recording know about that spider dog
well I had chilling man my boy got a spy
you're gonna put on his forehead now you
see it later so these guys what do they
do in the jungle they they build like a
nest well the cool thing about these
guys look he's so comfortable right now
Oh God God easy my feeling dude not
talking about my gang time I know I know
Mike's chillin despises chills chilly
one so in a while these guys lay out
like us like a don't let that high of a
web across the floor
right and they built like a little
trapdoor and like a and the edge of a
tree or under like a dirty log or
something of you know decay and log and
when animal is a little rodent or some
bugs that crawl across the floor it's
like a alarm system and they feel it as
soon as that that bug or something goes
across there they jump out of their hole
grab them up well they don't make spider
webs DS right right you know he's a
ground dwelling or tree dwelling spiders
interesting yeah bro yeah it's an
average-sized one that yes an adult some
get bigger than this I think the biggest
spider is a glider spider from South
America the birds it's crazy to get this
size at dinner please I've heard of that
yeah so your love of animals it
obviously transcends species what's your
favorite animal
I'm gonna go Jaguar Jaguar Jaguar I
played for the Jags yeah oh yeah good
Jags boy lowland Jaguars a badass bro
amazing yeah Jaguars anacondas well to
favor animals where's pit bulls but a
man's shirt join the podcast it's crazy
dude you want to cut them bring another
one in yeah sure man yeah let's bring in
something else bring me something else
is just speed this bad boy up at
something you were that pets
dude that's a big-ass tarantula man
that's a house spider in South America
yeah no way yeah I don't know dude
they're opening the big one-oh bait box
great they got a leash for something
come on tingling around holy [ __ ] what
kind of a snake is this bow reticulated
python python python so he's really big
you like to move around there's some
boots right there man all right Micra
power look back what do you got now man
this is the sonic big-ass snake golden
child reticulated python right motley
golden child motley golden charge see
that when I hit too light what does look
like like a rainbow right look at that
yeah it's amazing sin now people are
always scared of snakes right you think
they're slimy they think they choked you
and attack you it's not the case well at
all now this Manik is a top predator
where you come from
right come from Asia Indochina now these
snakes are classified as the real
man-eaters you know in the world hope
sorry I took my headphones off and the
reason why yeah oh yeah Ronnie's
straight this is a workout 24/7 that's
what I mean it goes around stuff don't
worry he's cool I think he'll be all
right he's gonna slither around you're
good don't worry don't worry don't worry
you're good I promise
[Laughter]
we're gonna do this from here I gotta
keep the head over yeah you guys so
really fast he pursues my mind
so look there's a monster right but he's
cool bro he means no harm no I don't huh
I don't know this snake he'll work to do
snake every day uh-huh so this is what I
explain to people I work with a lot of
animals especially
platform and most of the animals are my
first time interacting with them
and everybody sees these cool
experiences but you guys have been
almost brainwashed by the media for so
many years you know yeah oh this this is
evil this is bad this attacks you right
not the case at all right you know this
is this they can easily hurt me but he
sees no threatening us at all yeah
tomato now this is an apex predator so
in the jungle where he comes from he's
the top dog right you know nothing can
take him out of the wild except for you
know a human yeah or maybe a tiger or
something they come across backs but
interesting sick snake bro what does
this guy eat he'll probably anything he
wants anything he wants of course yeah
big rats rabbits guinea pigs whatever uh
you know there's necessar
you know a necessity for his diet in
captivity amazing in a while they'll eat
you know deers and
they'll eat a small rodents birds
monkeys there have been cases where some
people have been killed by these guys
crazy but it's not like a nice thing
ain't like a crazy thing that's
happening every single day you know yeah
I think it's only one real document of a
actual person being inside of a when I
was recently correct three of them yeah
but that's that's good for mice
throughout time on earth don't worry
buck you know I didn't bring anything
for you guys would get hurt I promise I
know it doesn't sound cool when I got a
15th place snakes with in my your feet
but yeah it here the thing listen I said
I breathe that's their breathing yeah
yeah I think this big snake has a big
long yeah no yeah you can hear it in a
parking lot really yeah and what's that
mean when he hisses back the [ __ ] up
yeah you know let's talk you know we've
got a snake moving around you want it
you want to bring him out in a wreck
with him later yeah okay let's do that
yeah ain't no way we're gonna bring
these big animals in here they're gonna
be moving around 24/7
crazy crazy
my place oh my god what is this yeah the
skin is really beautiful we should
cancel Donna's house that's too much to
bring the now you want you this look at
that guy smaller snake you would have I
would look at that side this is called
an African pixie frog pixie frog whoopsy
frog what the [ __ ] what does he do
he's a big-ass frog from Africa
sick right lazy you ever seen a frog
that big no no it's really amazing
of course he lives in like puddles of
water and stuff mm-hmm
that's awesome let's go get some
questions so tell us about this frog
right here it's an African African
picking strong these guys of course come
from Africa and you have different
species of frogs like pac-man frogs and
bullfrogs and tree frogs now these guys
live in law look it's a fly just flew on
top of him that fly doesn't not have a
clue
he won't even bother that fly yeah not
enough for yeah but these guys cool
about them live in Africa and they live
in small puddles of uh like okay so you
have a big lake right uh-huh
and then say it rains you got like a
little small puddle over here this frog
was a female will occupy that little
puddle she'll meet with her mate and
then she'll come in and she'll let all
her tadpoles in this little estuary a
little more small place and these
temples are raised up and the male's job
is to actually dig a canal trench oh boy
I've seen this Lake yeah you seen it on
that geo yes so they dig basically a
canal way passage wait for the water to
drain through the tadpoles living there
bigger but they have to raise them up a
little bit cuz you you know you lay them
out on the big you know open Lakes and
you got a lot of predatory fish or birds
and stuff that eats them yeah they can
have a little small lagoon they can stay
in they could protect them you know and
anything I wants to eat those little
small tadpoles the Big Daddy can come to
eat it this thing he's rats and snakes
and
his LEDs and scorpion anything that
comes by him I need to do it looks like
that's for sure
like have you been like how did you edit
yourself on you know all the intricacies
and the nature of these different
animals just an obsession man you know
like when you're obsessed with something
and you love something you study it all
ins and outs you know from watching
documentaries to reading books to
articles on the web to hanging out with
guys that you specialize in certain
species there's guys like like my boy
Jay the guy that brung the big snake
here yeah he specializes in reticulated
pythons even I told him or she knows
everything so after I do my research
yeah on the computer
Wikipedia encyclopedia you know articles
documented research and then after I
accumulated all that I attached myself
to a person that specializes in that
field because they have something
different right you know then the books
have because you spent so much real time
with your animals they know more the
personalities so that's how I learned
I'm a self-taught but I'm like a sponge
you know I love labs or literally
everything I always wanted to go to
school for this but I'm from the hood
broad couldn't afford to go to college
and you're beyond that at this stage yes
they're just educating yourself I like
to learn every day man you know I'm an
open book
I'm always attaching myself to something
to learn especially about it almost
every single day so you know and my mind
I don't know [ __ ] I love that to the
world they're like oh this guy knows
everything about animals in my mind I'm
like bro I don't know a [ __ ] thing
always learn you know always every day
bro yeah I love it
it's addicting it's awesome you know
well there's something you know that
Prague has the name I don't know it's J
what's his name's Jay what's the bull
frogs frogs name not the bullfrog a
pixie frog Gordo Gordo Gordo fat he does
he's the epitome of that oh there's
something really amazing about being
around these animals even though it's
it's pretty intense for a guy who's not
hanging out with them yeah it's very
grounding yeah you know you're very calm
you know spending time around them
seeing them and I'm up on the chair and
you're diving this guy here a panic
attack but at the same time there's
something very brings you right into the
moment you know very present to be with
these animals absolutely I mean I don't
ever you know tell anybody to go up in
the wild and do the stuff that they see
me do you know because of course it can
be dangerous animals are more scared of
us than we are with them yeah you know
and certain animals when they defend
themselves can be deadly to us sure so I
don't know about that any of us well you
gotta think really a cartoon frog oh
yeah the cartoon look real the pac-man
frog pac-man yeah the game pac-man they
have a frog game of pac-man frog that
eats everything Wow
so the name pack I don't know if it came
from the Frog but that's how they
correlate is it a big frog they get
pretty big not as big as this species
but they get really close with pac-man
frog yeah look at it moving I'm gonna
get my better lighting over here what's
up buddy or any of these animals
venomous no better venomous animals are
really dangerous right you know so you
can't bring around the public like that
because if you get bit you're getting it
a half a million dollar hospital bill
you can have nerve damage possible death
yeah so you don't want that unless
you're really experienced in that area
yeah are you serious oh yeah I have
hours with a bunch of venomous snakes
venomous cobras and gila monsters and
Gambas you know amazed all that stuff I
don't keep any eyes and my personal
collection cuz I like the touch [ __ ]
uh-huh you know you can't really handle
you can't handle but it's just I have
too many people around me my whole
family used to be around me growing up
you know and I would never put nobody
else in that type of danger yeah I've
always kept big snakes like that and
frogs and birds but as far as like
venomous animals yeah I can't break I
wouldn't be able to travel or sleep at
night know when a snake got out and my
family's at home you know sure so I
couldn't do that no now are they
different in their nature a venomous
snake too
one or another animal that isn't
venomous are they more aggressive are
they more or are they positive I would
say more so of how you approach them
that could every if every individual
animal has a personality like a person
does you know I have different
characteristics yeah so these type of
frogs have a broad character you know
frame yeah every individual one is
special you know so I spent 10 years
with 10 different frogs you know and I
know every individual frog on all yo
this frogs a dick
this frog super sweet disregards like to
be touched this frog doesn't like to be
out of water you know everybody everyone
is different one tolerates some other
than others interesting yeah some froggy
[ __ ] tell me about it about you and your
animals you've had animal stories I want
to hear these from you this guy what's
up buddy well Tiger the lines are
totally two different species of animals
they conduct themselves differently my
line is more you could domestic family
with the family and everything the tiger
I'm under depends on you individually
and the one else interesting well if you
ever had any uh memorable moments with
your animals that you just cherished
like oh man one day we go in the pool
the only thing soon they touch the water
that's when they [ __ ] yeah oh really
a lot of animals do that I can't have
that much fun with them you get really
good in the pool with like you know they
could carry me on their back and still
swim oh you're on grow strong as hell
yeah I love the water amazing dive deep
in Jaguar - yes yes stuff with the
Jaguars in South America when they jump
and crash the crocodiles yeah I love
thank dude it's amazing then they carry
it out yeah that's why I love Jags you
know yeah they're this don't give a [ __ ]
now do you have your own show yet you're
I'm working on some nice really
broadcast okay yeah okay I got some
always working on something well I feel
like I know
the world is in need of the next
generation of Steve Irwin man absolutely
man you know of course I'm myself but he
was my main inspiration for sure also
yeah it sounds amazing bro it's under
him I loved them and I never met him
yeah I talked to him but you know like
their father did so much for me you know
so I look at you know the whole animal
community has one community with the end
goal of helping animals yeah so I look
at everybody that's a family member if I
know if I don't yeah if you don't like
me I still love you because at the end
of the day we have it's not about us
it's about the animals you know I love
and so I I respect everybody in animal
world I love everybody in a world if
they don't like me or not yeah you know
I don't even care I love it
hey when he died from that us next thing
what that was just uncommon right yeah I
don't know exactly what happened no one
knows exactly what happened hmm
um but you know and some animals bro
they just have bad days you know some
animals get freaked out some accidents
happen you know and in the animal world
we get bit thousands of times if we
don't some people don't share it you
know I get bit thousands of times but I
never talking negative about the animals
because we're trying to build a positive
space for them you know in the world
so when freak accidents like that happen
you know it doesn't happen I saw one in
a million chance of something like that
happened you know people show my
stingrays with barbs all the time
sure you know it just happened to be our
Idol in a controlled environment with a
stingray that sub you know got stung
yeah you know and I said if he didn't
pull it out he would have lived is that
true again I have no clue you know about
the real actual story but um hmm I'm
sure uh I guess it was God's Way of
saying hey absolutely you know time zone
yeah mm-hmm Albright cry for weeks broad
and go to school but you know my friends
and family used to play the games all
the time all your buddy passed away you
know those fake news articles you see in
the in the grocery store yeah but it was
fake so many times you know I didn't
like guys shut up guys always mess yeah
um you know yeah one day when I you know
I knew was serious my mom was crying I
shouldn't know I was gonna be devastated
yeah and dude it was like
the worst days of my life I'm sure you
know but uh your idol goes down
everything happens for a reason man you
know I feel like sometimes people are
put on platforms to show what needs to
be done yeah and then you know look at
me and ten other people that are doing
it if you can make ten steve irwin's out
of one you know the same thing with me
if I can if I can inspire a generation
of animal lovers and I died tomorrow I
wouldn't give a [ __ ] I'll go to heaven
like a man cool I did my job
you know gonna be ten more mics and
steve irwin's and jeff corns and you
know yeah Dave outer boroughs ten years
from now that's the whole purpose of
what we do I love that man as a voice
for the voiceless what is it that you
want people to understand most about
these animals the real thing is we won't
survive without them hmm you know bees
go away trees go away certain animals go
wait
we're [ __ ] as humans yeah you know and
people don't realize that [ __ ]
you know look at the natural disasters
that happen look at though you know the
poaching happening Africa all that stuff
plays a valuable role in our lives you
know so if we don't protect these small
creatures the big creatures and
everything in between we're doing
ourselves yeah you know yeah and if we
can't coexist with them and we can't get
along with other species you know at the
end of the day we're animals too or Homo
sapiens we're the top predators in the
world right now humans are the animals
you know saying yeah so if we [ __ ] up
our own food chain we [ __ ] ourselves up
man that's that's like I like to keep it
100% real with the people because I feel
like so such traditions been happening
for so many years of raising awareness
and doing this and donate that but what
are y'all really doing because these
animals ain't being saved right so
that's the message I want to push to
people for the masses nice platform to
coexist with these animals because
without them there's no us and it sounds
like it's all this guy's crazy but it's
the truth man yeah now I mean that's a
big thing environmental conservation you
know it's a huge issue yeah and you know
there's I mean that's a that's a whole
day of discussion on its own
social media is only ten months old for
me you know the world just found out
with Tarzan was ten months ago Wow but
there's been my dream and passion since
I was a little kid
what was your coming-out party awesome
worldstar
oh really yeah I uh I ended up I was
supposed to actually quit my jobs this
year my birthday uh-huh and I ended up
leaving last year and do God put so many
blessings in my life like literally the
next day every year I start new goals
new year's resolutions but I started my
birthday
you know I started I start a new year
hold him I start a new year every year
my birthday man come up with new goals
new ideas to better myself all sarire my
future and I said man I need to change
my life up you know I need to go on
social media be more I'm an animal guy
but I hate people right you know I'm
saying I got bullied my whole life
people call me weird at braces the only
black kid that work with animals in the
hood so I've seen it all from you know a
youth perspective so I was never a
people person at all hated people it's
gotten a bunch of fights you know and
you can probably relate to this you know
people used to pick on me and I was
scared at first and then one day I'm
like actually the animals you know I
study them fighting and stuff I'm like
yo next person that folks in me i'ma go
ape [ __ ] on them bring the gorillas out
you know I love them then after that bro
it was like I went from alms you know I
hope no one bothers me today I wish a
[ __ ] would and that was it that
was a switch for me you know it was a
switch oh no that's just who I am
we know about I have a definitely a kid
audience but these messages aren't for
the kids you know these are for ya the
people with the checkbooks and no power
you know they need to hear our voices
did you hear their voices no doubt no no
so but it's probably for the most part
are already on this train yeah you know
and there's the real thar is that main
to fake one I'm gonna keep it real with
you but um that's awesome what you know
well so here we are man at the Tyson
ranch likes
badass cannabis operation huh huh now
something I don't know if you know this
or not but every animal and the animal
king
including humans have the
endocannabinoid system explain that what
is it
so the endocannabinoid system is a
system in our bodies that helps keep us
in homeostasis so our body produces
these chemical compounds that help keep
us in rhythm with our sleep our appetite
our mood helps us feel and deal with
pain and so endocannabinoids our mirror
replicas of these things that come from
the cannabis plant or weed that are
phyto cannabinoids they're the same
thing so our body produces these same
things that's what THC and CBD yeah its
cannabinoids they go into our bodies
they interact with our endocannabinoid
receptors and they help us you know deal
with inflammation keep us you know
sleeping well through the night help us
with our appetite our mood all this
stuff so every animal has an
endocannabinoid system now my question
is for you ndele cannabinoid
endocannabinoid system they can get high
yeah that's it so animals for instance I
give my dog CBD and a little bit of THC
is in English bulldog huh and it's great
for his hips
yeah no English Bulldogs have bad hip
dysplasia so it helps him dealing with
pain now are you in - are you a cannabis
guy you can really um I'm such a already
naturally - for sure no so I just
recently like literally a few weeks ago
started you know doing some cannabis
before bed because you know my whole
Tarzan project is exploding before my
eyes yeah you know and uh it's stressful
yeah a good way for sure man I'm so
obsessed with it for so many years you
know I'm doing everything hitting 16 18
hour days non-stop which I'm used to but
there's days where I have to get up
earlier but I can't sleep yeah you know
and I'm like dude I've never taken a
drug in my life yeah like a drug but
like I never been on prescriptions never
had anything wrong with me in my life
you know I took my mom like dude I don't
want to I don't want taking a medication
and go to sleep yeah but I clocked
ambien
you know yeah so she's like smoke some
weed all right
okay try it out see I'll go so you know
ticket do I have young baby girl lungs
you know yeah sure I hate it once now
hey man do you sleep that's one of the
best one once twice a week if I need it
but it's not it's like two weeks ago
turn it out yeah that's it I never sleep
either and but I the same I never took
them smoked never took a drug in my life
never drank
yeah Bailey's rang and I just started
that uh before I go to sleep the CBD oil
yeah I took a little lot yep and I slept
a little better yeah oh yeah dude I know
it's green of sweet times a night I'm up
five times ago yeah yeah man I live such
a focused lifestyle you know especially
now yeah you know everything's strategic
and precision it's like it's like going
to a training camp for a fight you know
yeah but um you got a lot going on you
got to kind of figure out what's best
for you you know you know and I've been
doing not really researched pipe and
I've been visiting the west coast a lot
recently and you know these guys are big
on a cannabis stuff so yeah you know I
was like dude to help you sleep
cool yeah for sure I feel every last
last thought it does it you know I don't
about it well I mean being with the
animals is super oh yeah this is like
for jacked up bro you don't even yeah
are on that man this is like remember I
see no interviewer Otto Schwartz [ __ ]
back in the day and he was talking about
how when he works out he gets a pump it
feels like he's having sex yeah you know
how it feels bro
you know yeah old I feel I don't feel
nothing yeah I don't think about nothing
I'm in pure happiness it's amazing I'm
so like there's been type lay college
football I played sports and all that
stuff so I found myself getting older
trying to please my parents and mmm you
know my family's full of athletes that
can be athlete too if I put my mind to
it yeah you know but I felt myself
trying to please them
I wasn't truly happy you know yeah and I
start talking in a couple of my college
teammates and I started really looking
that stuff like in a grand spectrum it's
like 2011 yeah you know he's I'm talking
to these guys about their passions I
hope I've been playing football since I
was 2 years old you know my father is an
NFL oh my brother is in the this cool
school you know I'm building a bomb on
it but who
these guys you know yeah and then we
play a game and the guy goes and blows
his [ __ ] knee up
yeah and I'm like it's all you know it
sucks yeah and like I like football I
could play I can hang with the best of
them I you know but I'm not gonna put
all this work into [ __ ] blow it knee
up yeah I'm up all this working I'm
gonna go get taken up by a Jaguar so I'm
more you know drowned trying to save
endangered fish on you know I'm saying
so love that I'm gonna put all my all
into something and be passionate about
it I'm gonna do exactly what I love so
I'll call my mom and like y'all I'm
leaving school Wow she knows I'm an
extremist you know when I say I'm gonna
do song yeah you best believe I'm gonna
do that [ __ ] Jesus Christ has to come
down himself and say hey Mike that's a
bad idea you know so if I had my mind on
something minister positive aspect
absolutely man you know I'm not gonna
stop so when I told my mom I was leaving
school she just broke down crying
because she I wasn't playing no games
yeah you know I went home for a while
then the story writes itself
well you were following your higher
power man exactly you know you're just
listening to that call and you had yeah
she actually discouraged me after school
cause I think she was more so upset
uh-huh you know and she was like the
home you know you can grow up we just
left school to go play with some
stupid-ass animals and that was the best
thing she could ever told me yeah you
know cuz it's my mom I love my mother
you know absolutely but when someone
something like that you all you just
gave me some more motivation through
some gasoline on this spot you
yeah I'll add me in couple months mom I
love it ma'am you know well it's all
it's all love she's very proud of you
know the stuff I do the positive energy
I keep the inspiration I keep with the
youth and you know I just want to make
my parents proud you know make myself
proud and keep myself happy that dude
looks like a little you know he's like a
little baby trying to take a nap I'm
gonna put him back in this off his box
with a bunch of water all right he's
trying up I ain't right still work so
you're chillin Mike awesome keep yeah
hey man somebody's got to do it
somebody's gotta do anything else urgent
somebody got to do it somebody has to do
it sure Mike what's what's next on the
docket for you man what are your plans
for the rest of the year and and what
are you looking forward to rested a year
my birthday's coming up so that means a
whole bunch of new stuffs coming
I got Africa coming up on that 11th of
November I may 24th I'm going to a high
poaching area oh wow and I'll go with
these uh these veterans they called vet
Paul and I'm friend of mine Timothy
Sykes they're going over there and I'm
gonna do some you know I have a big
animal platform with a bunch of eyes on
it so you know it's my job is what I do
and my job as a man to go over there and
bring light to the situation of all
these rhinos and elephants and animal is
decreasing you know and bring education
into the situation and educate the
masses on what is really happening
because these aren't getting covered
fast enough yeah you know rhinos and
elephants are dying and stings in five
years why the [ __ ] isn't everybody
talking about this so this is the last
the last white rhino just died yeah like
a southern white rhino the male had
passed away yeah but they think they
have some semen freeze you know they're
gonna try to impregnate uh females or
give them a black rhino or something
like that to help you know put a little
population and go out it sucks to have
to be like that you know but yeah
what is vet Paul it's a veteran's
protecting African wildlife views you
have viewers yes well we got 3.3 million
followers on Instagram all right oh we
got hundreds and millions of views on an
animal space across Facebook YouTube
Instagram awesome we got like 250 270
thousand subscribers on YouTube I'm
actually launching YouTube real heavy do
you get in the water with any animal
yeah well swimming like a fish hello yes
seep the love seat arrows love sharks I
got a bunch of tattoos on my leg full
underwater stuff oh I love that man I
love marine biology marine work and no
tagging you know
I love all this dude it's like it's
never ending it's awesome man you know
and the oceans relentless bro it's their
world you have no control in there what
do we got here swimming with a real
Jaguar there we go little monkey [ __ ]
me up in this video yeah he's trying to
keep him from crying
he's what to play yeah yeah he wants to
play I play with them it's called a
wrench mint Jaguars love water so you
know I wanted to know [ __ ] that speaks
to them wow that's the bigger one that
was his brother Wow
[Music]
that's a real apex predator right there
yeah dude it's a beast
your bathing suit matches yeah that's
wild
have you ever gone down to Mexico to see
that dude yeah I want to go you should
check that out I'd be interested to hear
your thoughts yeah yeah I want to go
down there and talk to them interview
them because I feel like a lot of people
have so many questions for them yeah you
know that our answer so yeah and again
you know we're all in the same we got
the same endgame exact so I'll let go
into places and you know asking the
questions
yeah you guys do and getting the answers
in helping people have clarity at people
if I can help his organization
yeah or anybody's organization have
clarity on what the [ __ ] going on over
there
it helps yeah you know yeah if someone's
doing bad doing bad things for the
animals negative aspect yeah it's gonna
get you know yeah it all comes to the
light yeah you know if you only have one
animal and North animals just one animal
what would you have works his ass off
bro well but no one have someone by my
side that works as hard I want to be
inspired you ever see ants ants are the
[ __ ] kings as a jungle Wow they come
at nobody [ __ ] with ants besides ant
eaters but um you know think about it
they they make their own ant piles they
they run the jungle they make pathways
they're there they're the numbers
just think about how many answer in the
world give it to camp I'll truly enhance
come out yeah it's like New York City
just birthed itself right than that
little ant pile I just think about it
there's like just say there's 70 ant
piles that big just 70 which is a very
very small number which is not it's
probably like 7,000 per couple hundred
feet Wow you know in certain areas yeah
so just say there's 70 am piles with a
million ants in each and each ant pile
and each state think about how many ants
there are and how they work if you put a
million ants in here we'd all be out of
here they work together they can live
like like Oh like 30-something times
their body weight right it's sick
it's crazy
Wow interesting answer that's what you
that I'm away you know he was close to a
hundred over a hundred yeah the first
one was the biggest Kent yeah
what is it what's number one time Tiger
nine and Jack tigers are bigger than
lions yeah be like five hundred you know
you like thousand pound was long yeah
yeah how tall are they eight feet yeah
standard Wow it's a big animal yeah its
massive targets at the time the longest
teeth how big was it
he's standing up in face seven feet and
then you had to give him to a place
right he got too big yeah people start
getting too freaked out about Oh baby I
was freaking out yeah I believe it and
you were the only one that had a
relationship yes true yeah
well Mike is there anything else p.m. I
don't wanna know I wanna I want to ask
some question from Mike yeah
dude go go go I'm a huge fan of boxing
and fighting yeah you know I like to
fight a lot hey you got the man right
here dude so when you would train him
back in the day how [ __ ] brutal was
it how would you put yourself through to
become the baddest man on the planet yes
what I want to know getting up to
different weird hours of the morning
training do the whole day pretty much
dude I watch a lot of your documentaries
and stuff and like what you got up here
and in here is [ __ ] sick well thank
you very much Michael and you yourself
inspire people like me you know people I
got a crazy work ethic myself you know
that I'm proud of but it comes from
people like you I study different
fighters different entrepreneurs on what
they all shared you know in common so if
I study five different people on five
different areas that they never ever
will cross paths and they all have one
thing in common is relentless hard work
mm-hmm it's like okay that's what I got
apply to myself to become a great
you know hotel when I when I operate my
everyday life I I'm trying to begin that
same level with Michael Jackson Mike
Tyson Mike Jordan and one day Mike
hosting I gotta get my bus on the ground
first you know what I'm saying
it's tone though it's also working you
got to earn your [ __ ] so one step at a
time one step at a time
absolutely I love that dude being the
champ I'm here with the champ my father
passed when I was 14
well one thing we shared a lot was you
were used to order two fights have all
the friends and family come over so we
used to watch ty suffice he should watch
Mike Tyson fights you know and we still
watch mayweather fights and UFC fights
and one of my good friends is our Tyrone
Spong
he's a bad [ __ ] too you know and
just I love fighting man yeah I love it
well I fight a little different than the
average human you know yeah I can take
some some styles from the anime yeah but
uh it's dope man being able to just be
be here no doubt you know we I'm not
here on accident
no hell no we're all here for a reason
and purpose absolutely so I appreciate
you guys having me on here let me share
my voice and what I'm about and I really
appreciate that from the bottom I heart
absolutely man we really appreciate
having you thanks for coming definitely
beautiful I love I love you guys I'm a
huge fan of Mike poofy and all you guys
so thank you guys thank you love you
guys like family you know [ __ ] a bro
love that all right guys it's great what
you're doing it's awesome man thank you
brother
yeah appreciate that keep doing your
thing down man no yeah God giving man
you know all right
well another great episode take time see
you guys next time peace
[Music]